welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm very excited to
be joined by ben
muwoki who is currently the managing
director of source group international's
american business
and who operate in several states such
as la
new york and soon to be launching in
chicago
ben entered the recruitment industry in
2001
where he joined s free and he stayed
there for
19 years where he climbed the ranks from
recruiter
all the way to vice president of sales
and
and this is where he's responsible for
five distinct brands
across seven locations in north america
before he left
to join sgi to head up their american
division in
2020. ben thanks for joining me
thanks for having me here excited to uh
to talk
yeah really looking forward to this so
what we always like to to start
um on this show is in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up
a highly successful recruitment
consultant
yeah i've been asked this question a lot
over the years
and there's no better answer i feel than
one i got from uh
one of my md's a guy called daley
thompson and he instilled into me this
belief about three p's
um purpose persistence and pride
and so although those are obvious in
their definitions
um there are often many people that
don't
have a purpose-driven approach right
they will just turn up
and you know one day they might be on
another day there might not be
the people that i've seen the most
successful who sustain success
have got clarity in terms of where
they're going and why and what they do
whether that say
money-driven career-driven uh any other
types of aspirations they really won't
know what i want to go for
and of course you want people who are
resilient of course
people that can see through but being
able to
understand that it's it's not it's not
you
right you know you're gonna make
mistakes look forward to the
failure and understand that there is
there is success at the end of that and
so that
that level of persistence the job that
we do
is often being said is it it's not
rocket science it's not that the
difference is your application
your ability to want to work through
and and then pride really caring about
what you do
right so that job qualification doing it
to the best of your ability asking the
questions that make the difference
following up with the candidate even if
you even if you don't have
feedback for them i'm priding in your
service and so
those are those are the three things
that i i really believe
stand the test of time and every top
biller or producer
that i've ever seen or met they have
those three things um in in some way
yeah well yeah i really like how you
write that yeah
sharing that with the three pieces
that's really interesting so
just to tee this up for everyone so
obviously worked at s3 for for a long
period of time and across that time you
worked in different locations
started in the uk moved to amsterdam in
that time
new york and then later chicago which is
where you're sort of based now
and then obviously 2020 moved to sgui
where
you're based in chicago and helping them
grow their american business right so
we're going to
unpack this but i'll be honest with you
ben
i haven't had loads of uh recruitment
professionals on here who
um have come from the infamous s3 brand
right so i'm more i only knew about s3
when i'm when i moved up to
to london and sort of got sucked into
this whole world of recruitment right
so i i i'm always curious to hear from
different people's stories
and journeys as to like how they would
describe it so how
firstly would you describe your first
year in recruitment and then
laterally like how would you describe
the s3 culture that sort of
has really stuck with you when you look
back into those years
yeah sure i i look back at my time s3
really fondly
uh it's it's the time that shaped me
professionally it's giving me
all the career opportunities that i've
asked for and more
so there's there's lots of there's lots
of fond memories
when i first started february 28 2001 i
joined with a
brand called recruit first that's later
later that's murdered
into others um i i remember it was a
baptism of fire
there was a great bunch of people
thirsty for activity
um and um it was
it was fierce right um there was great
training there was great application but
there was a
an absolute uh understanding that
you needed to get on with it right you
needed to be able to
ask the questions understand what you
need to do but then just execute
and so like many i went through that
roller coaster
um i remember my first lunch clubs which
were amazing
i remember uh blanking which was
devastating
um but all all the while i looked back
at that
that first year and i it was a real
lesson
and the the biggest lesson for me
was was really about the one one of
those three p's i talked about earlier
um about purpose i i turned up thinking
i've got this i'm gonna really i'm gonna
really crush it
and there were there were certainly
moments or some months where
i was fully at it and that translated
into my performance
and then there was other other months
excuse me where i
i believe my own i believe my own hype
right and so i because i did well i i
i took my foot off gas a little bit
and and then that translated in
important forms
and so it really took me about six to
nine months to
to figure out that i needed to create
this
calm in my approach and that that's how
i'm going to be able to
um deliver further on and uh
your next question about the culture
i think any great organization
they start with their people right and
that's that's certainly true of my
experience
at uh s3 lots of the people that i
worked with then
i i count as as good close friends
today some some i'm working with you
know we've gone round the circle
and i'm working with them back at uh sgi
um but yeah it's it was people i i
i want to be inspired by
colleagues by staff that i work with i
love the idea of being reversed mentored
and so i've always had that
um access and and also believe in the
journey that the
person i'm working for so that's what
allowed me
or gave me the drive to to want to stay
at history for as long as i did
to go to the different locations because
there was always there was always um
somebody i could i could go to battle
with there was always somebody i
believed in
that um this journey was was worth
fighting for you know and um and being
surrounded by people that are willing to
go on that journey and really you know
uh sink themselves in
it's really fulfilling right you you you
feel like you're
the sense of togetherness is is so
strong
and um and they they back you right and
you know if you if you've got if you've
got the ability you've got the
ability to uh take on something big and
you've executed
they'll give you not they gave you me an
opportunity in multiple locations
and so that just gives you that feeds
the engine and gives you the
the uh the desire to move forward yeah
that's really interesting so
just just out of curiosity so how old
how old was he when you
joined them uh i was 20
21 okay 21. okay okay interesting right
so so it says two things i just want to
sort of um just dig a bit deeper in
there so the first thing because we're
talking about it like
from europe in your opinion then what
what were the sort of three
non-negotiables of the s3 culture that
you think
they abided by that that made up the s3
culture if
people didn't abide by these three top
things
what were they
um so in no particular order i would i
would say
the thing that really stands out is um
you need you needed to um be like one
sill right you need to
do what it says in the tin if you said
you're going to be able to deliver on
this particular kpi this particular task
then go and deliver it
right and and that that was certainly
expected
um being in the environment i was in
being a team player
what was really important so you know
um cross-selling breaking into
customers for for other people pulling
jobs for other people
you would do this long before there were
deal splits wrong long before
you would get something for it you would
you just did it because it's the right
thing to do
um and and you knew that you know what
if i
if i break in and play my colleague in
is better for the brand better
better for me better for the business
and uh
and i think i think the other thing was
was really having fun right because
there's such a strong
work uh mentality that the
the the culture was um
really deeply manifested in having a
good time whether that was at your desk
whether it was after hours whether it
was at lunch clubs incentives or
you know over the weekend you really you
really gel together right so this this
idea that
many people would have talked about but
work hard play hard was
was a thing right and and um the people
that
tended to enjoy that people that
embraced that
um were people that would excel in that
environment
yeah really interesting and the the next
thing that i just wanted to hear from
you so just to give me
an idea of timeline so when you when you
joined
obviously i know you said that it was in
um yeah it was um a perm
biller what was the timeline before you
then got the opportunity to go to
amsterdam
just really quickly yeah so i joined
february february 28
2001 and i uh launched our
business in amsterdam in june 1 2008
2000 okay so seven seven years and yeah
i guess building your professional
equity of that business and
getting the opportunities in these
things and then before you um
launched that was you in a management
position
or was you still in just a producer role
or both
um no i i'd work my way up to a manager
position
actually before moving to amsterdam
the brand i was with at the time was
going to launch in new york and this was
going to happen in 2007
and so i put my hand up and uh got
accepted to launch alongside a handful
of other
individuals and of course the financial
crisis happens
and so i was we were meant to go in
2007.
the ceo at the time and my md at the
time you know broke the news
and said we can't we can't go to new
york and
so that was pretty devastating but
after two weeks i came back and i just
told my md that look the destination of
new york it sounds fantastic but it's
the opportunity that i want and so
you know it doesn't need to be new york
and and
two weeks later we started building our
plan for amsterdam and then went six
months
six months after that okay and so so
just to be clear because i know um i
work with some businesses that just
recruiting their amsterdam space so was
there no
s3 footprint there before you went there
yeah there were other brands the brands
that i had
was a brand uh called madison black um
at the time there it was huxley
progressive and computer future as well
yeah
yeah because i thought there were some
people there yeah okay yeah so what what
i wanted to know that that context
really helps and for people listening so
what i just wanted to know
ben in like your opinion is what you're
talking about there is that you
yeah you you put your hand up and you
got accepted right so what i'm really
curious about is like
why was it that ben was able to get
those opportunities and not others
like we've been talking about is a
competitive it was high standards
environment
um there was fierce competition but it
was also a team player so
i just want to know sort of from your
opinion like why was it
that ben got those opportunities and not
the person sitting next to you that
may have similar ambitions
well i can't talk for other people i can
i can only talk about my
my uh ambition and
what i wanted and so i started off the
conversation talking about being
purpose-driven that was something that
was drilled into me
and because i i led and still lead with
my purpose it was clear
that i wanted to do more and so at the
time there was a great talent
of um leaders at madison black
and i looked around and i felt like the
best way for me to
to scale up is to to go abroad and so
at the time not many of the my peers at
madison black wanted
or were prepared to do that starting
young families
and so that that gave me the edge by my
willingness to get out of my comfort
zone
and and then and then communicating to
my
uh to my leaders about my desire to do
that and my flexibility right so
i wanted to go to new york i started off
telling that story
my wife and i got married um
faster than we were going to just so
that my wife would be able to get a visa
and so we and we sold we sold everything
uh and we created our a dollar fund
uh and you know three months later we
were told we're not going to go to new
york we're not going to launch
right and so they've been able to pivot
and and just think right okay you know
it is what it is
we still want to go on a journey and
then taking that opportunity to
amsterdam i think i displayed
flexibility
um and and and that was something that
the the leadership
you know ended up backing no i really i
think
the key part that i keep finding when i
sort of ask questions around this that i
think people should really
take away and put an underline around is
is when you said that you
you let your leaders know and you
communicated that
because i think sometimes i'm sure
you've experienced this now right i
think sometimes people can fall in the
trap of expecting
expecting those opportunities to come
but actually the best thing to do is
actually over communicate so if i'm
someone working your team now and this
is sort of i have an
idea of where i want to go whatever i
should be communicating that to you and
my manager going hey
like this is how i'm thinking about the
future this is sort of where i want to
go because
when you're then having business
strategic meetings around how we're
going to grow the business you know then
oliver and such
and such has said to you well actually i
know well this is sort of somewhere
where ollie wants to go whatever do you
get what i'm in
so i think that that's that i really
like that you shared that
yeah i look certainly communicating your
your ambition
communicating your desire is absolutely
true from
for from as an individual contributor
and i think as the leaders
need to also have the conversations with
staff because some staff
might not yet be comfortable in putting
their hand up they might think oh you
know
am i not um am i not credible enough and
so
it's a two-way street i was lucky enough
that that conversation
happened that way um but the other thing
that's
that's really important i think is
understanding that opportunity doesn't
always come
at the right time and it doesn't come
doesn't come gift wrapped
right so often lots of people will think
about
right i want to go to this destination
and then they're fixated on that
destination
and and if that if that doesn't happen
then it's there's devastation
and so in in my personal experience for
me
and people that i know there is there is
no path that is linear
right it's literally up and down and so
i i gave you my my first story i wanted
to go to new york
we got we we sold everything that we had
uh
of the the gifts for for our wedding
were dollars right
our honeymoon was in new york and
we were told you know and then two weeks
later sorry we're not going to new york
and so
you have a choice at that moment right
it's like you can either be devastated
about this
american dream that i had or look at it
and say well actually
do you know what was more important was
getting an opportunity
new york is just one jacket so i took
that jacket off
and put on my amsterdam jacket if that
makes sense right yeah
and and then you know four four and a
half five years later i'm in new york
and so i got to where i wanted
i got there i got there in a better
position actually as well
after working in my time in amsterdam
and
i was also better suited to it because
i've now worked in in two different
locations
rather than just from the uk so that's
what i mean about
opportunity doesn't come gift wrapped if
you if you communicate
but also have the flexibility that
that's where i want to go
they might be different steps along the
way that that to me
is where as a leader who i talk to to
individuals about
that that's where i think somebody can
stand out can have that edge
because what you do today isn't what
you're going to do tomorrow
but lots of people sometimes
i think have a too much of a blanket
approach yeah
i need to be yeah i need to be in this
stop this position this is this
it's like it doesn't work like that well
certainly it didn't work like that for
me
yeah but at the same time that's what i
actually gave you the competitive edge
yeah no that thank you for sharing that
that's really interesting so
i want to dig into the sort of nuances
of going into a different market
that sort of um we can talk about new
york amsterdam and the nuances of those
different markets and
going into these um places and adapting
et cetera because i'm sure there
would have been even more flexibility
when you entered these new environments
right but
just because you've spoken about it
quite quite a bit i want to
ask you this question now and it's about
purpose right it seems like you've
really anchored onto that
that sort of really helped you along
your career right and i think
what i love about your story is that
you've you've built a system
clearly you've built a sustainable
career right and you hear about a lot of
people enter the recruitment industry
and then
and then leave it but you you've built
um you've worked to one particular
company for a very long time
right so the purpose piece you're
hearing that a lot more now i think
the cover period would have really
tested people's purpose right i'm sure
you've even experienced that yourself
so i guess the question is if i'm
listening to this right now i might be
someone else in my recruitment career
and that might be a bit i don't know
that might be difficult for me to sort
of uncover or think about or talk to
and i don't know i might find it
difficult to uncover or
i might be someone listening on later on
down my career where i've had more time
to work that out
so i guess the question is like how can
the people listen to this how can
recruiters listen to this sort of tap
into that
purpose which really is important for
longevity and sustainability in
in recruitment how did you tap into it
and does it change and yeah just
i guess talk a bit about the purpose bit
and your journey with that
yeah i i think that's spot on hashem
um like like i mentioned
in my experience the people that are
genuinely purpose-driven
in whatever vocation but we're talking
about recruitment but in whatever
vocation
uh time and time again you will i will
see them
achieve above and beyond their
expectations
so i guess i was i've always been
purpose or target driven
um if i think about school i think about
sports i think about the things that
interested me when i was growing up
there was always
something that i was running after but
it wasn't until
an early md of mine you know framed it
in this way for me
and so what i needed to do at that time
was self-reflect
and and just ask myself the questions
what does that mean
and and i won't you go through the kind
of what why how when
you know uh question technique so
at the time i was unashamedly
materialistic
and what i meant by that was um i wanted
i wanted to create
a a platform for my my wife and i i
wanted so whether that was
investments whether that was holidays
whether it was restaurants whatever it
was
i was knew that i needed to be able to
build a certain amount to get there
and and i would ask myself why why why
do i care about that
what what is it that makes me want to
get out of bed
and i keep asking that question why
until i found something
right and that was that was where i
would go oh that yeah that is what's
going to make a difference
because i'll have just as many bad bad
days as everybody else
just as many bad weeks you know that
having a purpose doesn't mean
you you you beat that having a purpose
just means you reduce the time
uh that you uh feel sorry for yourself
right yeah
where you feel like oh the world's
against me it's like well
it's not it's not actually against you
um what are you gonna do
to to move the needle forward what's the
thing that's pushing you
um and so i've talked to so many people
in my career
and have and supported them through that
you know
sometimes it's learning somebody some
people want to
um learn a particular skill a particular
tactic that that's what gives them their
energy
other people it's self-development other
people's sense of
victory other people it's recognition
there are a number of different things
that um give you your spark give you
your joy
and and so you have to have a you have
to have a moment of
self reflection and then don't take it
like uber seriously but like set maybe a
six month goal
sometimes 12 months is a bit much for
some people right just set six months
and just go
what would i how do i want to feel in
six months time like what would that
look like so if i did this how uh you
know would i like the look of it
how do i how i feel what would it what
would it feel around me
and and then you kind of visualize that
that sense
and then and then you work backwards
okay so what will i need to do to
achieve that and you know some people
have post-its on their pc some people
uh post this or their mirrors in their
bedrooms or whatever however you need it
to visualize and
and remind yourself use that um
but tap into it particularly through
the tough times but also um don't ignore
it when you do well
because it's always good to confirm um
what it is that you're working towards
and then assess once you've achieved it
it's like great do i want to double down
and you know earn more money or do i
want to do i want to do this
whatever the purpose is certainly unique
to you but
i i i find it very difficult
for uh for anybody if they don't have
if they don't have that then i don't
understand what you're working towards
you know um a promotion a lot of people
say i'm working towards a promotion
that's brilliant of course it is but
once you hit that promotion what's next
right you know a promotion i feel like
should be
part of your journey but not not the
destination not not the end of your
journey it's a byproduct of you
it's a recognition of you doing well
when you're getting there so what it
what is
what is it that um is going to take you
through that promotion
and not just that first promotion the
next promotion that to me is when you're
clear on your purpose
you can explode but if you're just sat
there thinking oh i'm just going to get
promoted to be a senior con or a
principal con
i think you're missing your potential
you're missing the opportunity to
discover what's what's great about you
yeah no i i think you spoke about that
really well i'm glad you brought out so
i think the key things that i took there
to sort of
put that together is yeah ask yourself
why you want that or this or whatever it
is
more than more than once right to sort
of go back that onion and
yeah try and find that anchor point and
i think the other part there you've
i agree i think the best recruiters i've
interviewed on this show one of the
common traits is definitely
willing to self-reflect or that's
something that something that they
actively do right being willing to go
right what why this week what didn't
that call went badly what could have
done to improve it etc etc right
so so i think but and then the other
part that you mentioned there which i
think is really important
is that destination piece right because
i've spoken to a lot of
high highly successful recruitment
professionals who
have maybe been too reliant or put too m
too much emphasis
on the destination if that's achieving a
certain paycheck if that's
getting the promotion as you said when
you then get there
and i don't know if you've ever felt
this but then it's like oh wow okay
this doesn't feel as great as i thought
it would or it doesn't last as long as
you thought it would and then it's like
what next
what now and that's why you're well
that's why you're talking about
that potential miss of your own
potential if you don't dig that bit
deeper because as you just said if you
dig that bit deeper
and you really have clarity on why and
where you're going
then these promotions and these
destinations along the way will be a
by-product
so if you listen to this yeah explore
that
you should really explore that yeah 100
because promotions work for some people
and for others
it doesn't mean so much right it might
be excellence
in their field it might be um
it might be something else and so often
you join an organization and you just
you look forward and you think right
okay the way for me to progress
is my career and that's fantastic of
course and you know
i hope your organization has got a very
clear path for you for you to do that
but don't just tap out of that area to
you know think think to yourself
where else can i where else can i excel
what's going to make me happy
what where where else can i take take
myself and so
learning a new skill within the job that
you're doing
i don't know maybe maybe you're um
you're
you're a great recruiting consultant but
you haven't done any networking yet
right you could do that a bit better
maybe you haven't sold
sold a particular element in the job
maybe you haven't done retainers before
or you have but only a few how can you
learn that expertise
maybe maybe you haven't done any
cross-selling into different
product lines there are many different
ways that you can
get deep in in the job that can feed
your purpose
um and so yeah i i completely agree it's
you've got to have clarity um so that
you can just
fly through right um and
i i i think if you ever find yourself
having a what next moment
then then pause right and and then and
then go and go again with that
self-reflection yeah okay
really really enjoyed that so i'm i'm
really excited to dig into
a bit more like tactical practical
things here with you so
just for context for me and people
listening when you went to amsterdam
and also new york and beyond did you
typically
go into those environments at a senior
level would you
um billing at that point just to give me
a bit of
context so then i can make sure i ask
the right questions
yeah of course when i when i launched
amsterdam with with the team i i wasn't
billing at that particular time
okay and that and and as i as i grew
my my role became larger with with great
complexity
so my position um skill set was much
more strategic
okay and was that echoed in new york or
yeah so when when we launched in
amsterdam we started with
with five uh it was a fantastic
uh experience and we we built
and i ended up being asked to manage um
different businesses and so i built my
my um
scale if you like up to 45 people
and then moved to new york and that team
was 12.
so so um
i mentioned that because when gary elden
who was the
ceo at the time talked to me about
america because he knew
i wanted to go five years prior um i
built myself to this position
i was um on the board in in the in the
dutch business
i was running two brands um you know 45
people were looking to take that to
60 70 80 and he was like well there's an
opportunity
in new york but it's 12 people so
you know um that didn't matter to me it
didn't matter to me because
i knew i knew what i wanted was the
opportunity and i knew i could take
my time from 12 to make it 130 which is
what i ended up finishing with
so the um the
the skill set that i employed in all of
those jobs was talking about
um trying to make sure that we've got
the right uh access
to to talent right trying to make sure
that we've got the right up taking our
opportunity to market
and then you know building the talent
pipeline to to execute on that and grow
and
um fortunately enough i was able to
surround myself with some great people
and that's that's what we did
okay that's really good content so then
just to be clear then so you
when you went into new york again in
that more strategic
growth position and by the time you left
to join sgi
it went from 12 to over 100 people that
you was
yeah so the the responsibility that i
had
um grew from december 2012
until um the end of uh
uh to 2020. um i i managed 130 people
across
across brand so i went from one team
yeah one team
um perm in new york to
um five brands seven locations all of
perm across
america okay cool so first thing i want
to dig into and then i'd be keen to
then dig into more practical things
around client development and
these types of things that a lot of
people always want to hear about right
so
the first thing i have to ask you i do
get these questions quite a lot
and it's around the nuances of the
different markets right
i think from the conversations that i've
been having
i think if you're a recruitment business
or a recruiter that
did diversify your business as in not
just be reliant maybe in in one
particular location that you recruited
or in one particular market you had a
better chance of thriving rather than
just surviving
during the coving period right so i do
feel like there will be a lot of
businesses
um that will be continuing to diversify
if that's opening up
new um markets in different countries
etc so
if we start with amsterdam first then
what would you say were the main
sort of different new nuances that you
had to adapt to or learn the hard way
and then we'll go to america just
quickly to hear your take on that
were these people super direct and you
had to always go through internal
recruitment i don't know what were the
sort of key maybe one to three things
that you really had to adapt to that you
think are specific to the amsterdam
marketing region
right so we started trading into
amsterdam from
from london before we uh yeah we landed
where
we had a you know soft uh soft launch if
you like and
uh the the dutch are famously direct
which is which is uh which is fantastic
actually because
you you actually know where you stand
the difficulty
the difficulty that we had were that we
weren't we didn't speak dutch
right um we we had we hired us
one guy at the beginning of the launch
and he spoke dutch and so
he had to become our translator in lots
of situations
and so um communication was difficult in
some circumstances
and so having to be direct was was was
really important
i think the other the other thing that i
really really stan
stands out was that
the dutch were quite tolerant um and
they would give you they'll give you a
chance they
were willing to work with you um and
uh you know forgive if you demonstrated
that you
you were working hard right if you could
show that you were
you're partnering with them that was
slightly different to my experience in
the in the uk
when i was leading then because sure we
had some great relationships with
and partnered with some great customers
but it was it was much more
transactional
and so coming going to europe mainland
europe was the first time that i really
uh felt like you could you could create
partnerships and that's that's
really been the case in the us and so
that was the first transition where
i was like well okay wow you know we can
really do something together here and be
viewed as a partner rather than just be
viewed as a supplier
and then all the kind of negative
connotations that come with that you
know
you you can't really get the best out of
each other uh and so
yeah those were the two things that
stood out to me of my time holland
nice that that that's great i think
that's really interesting and then
let's just then go into america then so
some of the things that i've heard and
we've heard in this podcast are
can definitely make more money fees tend
to be typically larger
um corporate recruitment internal
recruitment are definitely people that
you want to have on your side
and you may actually piss more people
off and
um reduce your potential if you just do
like the typical thing in the uk right
bypass those people and just speak to
the hiring managers and
maybe secondary be concerned about
building relationships with internal
um and then also then the common things
that we've heard of them
actually like the lack of competition
that there are obviously
there are competitors right but the sort
of just mass scale of america
and actually the there's so much
potential and opportunity
because there are far less recruiters
compared to the the uk
in america right so i guess nuances in
america that you
obviously now are accustomed to and know
that you think would be beneficial
for people to understand and know from
like someone like yourself who's been
operating in that market for
for a while now right so
the the things that you've mentioned are
certainly my experiences
as well right there there is there is a
wonderful opportunity to create a
platform of excellence
right there the fees uh certainly
do offer a greater upside than perhaps
some parts of
the world um but it's not for nothing
right you you can't just land and just
expect
uh high fees you got to be able to still
demonstrate your value
and and i find the um
american experience quite similar to to
the dutch
in in as much as they're very willing to
partner
they're very willing to give you a
chance
because you know sales and recruitment
is a
it's a much more respected profession in
america than it might be in other parts
of the world and so
you know they they they get that you're
you're trying to make a difference
but they'll certainly hold you to a high
standard um
you are able to i think demonstrate your
value and and look for
uh better margins but again at that
with with those customers you've got to
be able to to show how you can stand out
and it's
it's got to be greater than oh i can
find you a candidate
so what so can so can everybody else um
what what what companies are really
looking for
is greater than contingent is how can
you how can you take us
on this journey you know i don't need
you just to send me
and place one kind of a hero there how
can how can you really add value to the
business and so
being able to demonstrate that is is
really important
um having having um
a niche focus it's it's often said but
it
it can't be it can't be overstated um
this idea of being a jack of trades or
you know jack of all the master of none
it just doesn't work i've i've seen so
many people
you want to conquer all of america it's
just too big
it's really really too big you need to
be able to
you know coin the phrase um inch-wide
mild deep
that that's where you make make your
difference and that's actually where
your your your customers see your value
because most of the competition
the american staff and businesses don't
generally operate a 360 model
they have a you know 180 they have an
account team and people on delivery
and those people on delivery are largely
um cross-vertical
and so you know they will find
candidates
you know the periphery and so if you can
demonstrate your expertise and find the
top ten percent that they can't find
that's your edge and and um and so
having that expertise
is is vital it's very tempting i don't
know if you're in new york to start
trading into boston or trading into
philadelphia
but there's plenty for you to go after
if you are in in one location
have that commitment yeah okay
interesting right
so so i'm keen to go into the more sort
of tactical things day to day that
obviously you've been in the in a sort
of way and i guess i'm assuming with sgi
you're in a similar role now where your
response for the growth and strategy
for the business right but in america so
i guess what
what people always want to know about
ben is is the sort of new business
element
right i don't it seems like it's just
always the most popular area that where
people want to develop and improve
and and sort of master right so i guess
let let's start here so
maybe we can take you can take this sort
of last six to 12 months
because let's keep it sort of currency
today
over the last six to twelve months like
in your opinion from what you've seen
from
people in your team and people that
you've managed like what have been the
sort of one or two
ways that have been the most effective
for your guys and girls to win business
and
form client relationships and new club
relationships would you say
it starts with the um
you've been an expert right okay it's
this is this is such a
it's such an obvious thing to say but so
many people
don't operate this way right they
understand it but they don't believe it
and so the people um in our current team
that
that are standout great performers and
people that i've managed before they're
they're in the center of
of their hurricane if you like right
there they're the center of the storm
and so what i mean by that is
they um they they will know the top 100
top maybe 150 candidates say you're on
perm
that are in their vertical but in my in
my
in my humble experience i don't think
you need more than about 150 to 200
candidates
top candidates in your particular market
for you to
execute and be a top top top biller
right
the difference is the difference is
understanding who they are
and keeping in contact with them too
many people
um give this business a really bad name
because they ghost
right they talk to you the first time
and if you if you're good or no good
then then you're gone you miss that deep
expertise you miss that deep knowledge
and so if you focus on your community
and you build it out
they become your advocates and so
almost everybody that i've ever seen
build a business other than their
you know their ability to work hard you
know
find a pool of candidates very quickly
what you'll notice is that they break
into accounts based on their
relationship
somebody has recommended them somebody
has gone internally and advocated for
them in a really strong way
somebody has said hey you should work
with xyz
and and that is is how they are breaking
into
other division lines within those
organizations
or how they're breaking into those
organizations because the candidate that
they worked with over here
they've got such a great relationship
with they moved on and
they can they can play them in you know
i think i think gone are the days where
you just want to blindly do a send out
and just think oh that's going to
open me business you might open
something sporadically but it's the
relationships that you
that that will open genuine doors for
you and you can't build those
relationships if you don't have
expertise
and your expertise doesn't need to be
just within your market
sure you need to know the tactics you
need to understand
how your market operates but your
expertise is recruitment
and that is what people look for and
that's in my opinion that's how you can
stand out
and time and time again i see and hear
the teams talking about
oh this person has introduced me over
here
hey you should talk to this person
because of
x and it's and it's and it's always and
it's always
boils down to that relationship it
really it really does
so how do you build and nurture your
community you can you can do that
via personal branding lots of people
will be using linkedin and
other platforms to communicate which is
fantastic
there's um you can you can have your own
uh community in terms of networking
events
when we're allowed to see each other um
or virtual at the moment
um you know but but the the thirst
to build and feed that community is is
what makes a difference
and then that community will feed you
back
yeah that's great i think i mean you may
have answered it but
my next question was just gonna be sort
of in your opinion what's the sort of
one
most important thing recruitment
consultants listening to this
need to master and why
when it comes to maybe new business but
i don't know maybe you just answered it
it's relationships but
what comes up for you for that like if
people listening could really
become a master at i know there's a
multiple tudor things that you need to
do but
what comes up for you
you've got to have credibility and so to
create credibility you've got to know
what you're talking about so you've got
to know
you've got to know your your your um
your personal market but you've got to
understand recruitment you've got to
understand push and pull factors you've
got to be able to offer
advice you can't just rock up and just
say are you looking for a job
like that's that's such a basic
interaction
right you need to be able to understand
um
the desires the needs the push and pull
factors that operate in your market and
talk to somebody
about that and so i often talk about
the first time you talk to somebody it's
not
the goal is not oh i need to place you
to tomorrow today or tomorrow
yeah the goal is i want to get to know
you i'm going to place you at some point
right it might be today it might be next
year and i think if you take that
approach and you
and you're committed to that approach
remember i talked about
identifying your network and then just
constantly running around it right
constantly talking to people constantly
building sticking in your niche you will
build a reputation
right you'll get a reputation as you're
reliable right because you keep in
contact
you build a reputation as you're honest
right because you're doing the same the
things that you said you're gonna do
and that is what people buy people buy
that
they they don't they don't buy the oh
i've got five years experience in this
so what right so does everybody else
that calls me up
what they want to be able to see is that
how you're how you can make an impact to
them and so
that that is what i would say is is is a
credibility and a commitment to to that
uh
idea um call back people
um have them in your list get to know
them um
understand what what what what what they
care about if they've got a family know
they
know them right if if they um what are
their interests how can you build that
relationship if you
if you're not committed to to doing the
hard yards
um but your question was what's what's
the biggest difference
or what what what can people what what
do people need to really master
yeah so so i think we talked about that
from a new business point of view
of course there are different approaches
different markets that need slightly
different nuanced approaches
a question i often ask and the
individual needs to have this
self-reflection is
how do you win right so what is it
in your market that makes the difference
so if you're on perm
generally your objective is obviously to
get jobs but it's it's really
interviews is a currency right you need
to be able to get
a consistent number of interviews in
your in your marketplace for you to be
relatively successful so how do you win
what is it
that you need to do to create that for
you is it
you've got you've got a head hunt um
candidates because your canada pool
isn't big enough or if you've got a big
enough canada pool i need to keep in
touch with them
there are there are a myriad of
different things but if you zero in on
that
the outcome will be will be the
interviews
on contracts the thing that will make
the difference
is the amount of committed jobs that you
have a b jobs is
how i would refer to them so who how are
you going to do that
right um where are you going to find
these pockets of business lines in in
customers
and so those are the tactics that will
vary
based on your experience based on your
market based on your region
but the question should always be how do
you win
what are the things that you need to
execute on a daily basis
and if you commit to that the rest
follows
and so when i was when i was growing up
in the business the thing that
made the difference to me was being able
to uncover or generate or regenerate
two unique candidates a day right so i
knew if i found
two unique candidates a day that i could
then sell out to my live jobs and then
you know
spec out to other companies that i felt
that would make a difference
i knew if i could do that so 10 a week
and i could send them each to at least
10 different places
that's going to create an opportunity
for me to pull jobs and get interviews
and conversely if i did not do that i
didn't get the interviews that i needed
to have so i didn't i didn't um obsess
so much about jobs
i didn't obsess so much about interviews
i obsessed about finding those
candidates
and my criteria was clear they needed to
be um
in my market they needed to have a
certain depth of experience
they need to have a certain type of
profile and i obsessed in that world
and then that i knew if i found that
person i could get them two three four
interviews
it just happened i knew i could pull a
job i knew i could get their place
yeah so that's how i that's how i won
and
everybody i work with i would try to
drill down and just
get really to the nub of it that's
that's the difference maker
yeah honestly i love how because i love
that asking that question how do you win
and i think what what
the way that you've articulated that and
bro i think what i love about that is
that
you've you've made it when you really
dig down and think about those things it
then becomes really simple
or like really clear what you need to
focus on because as you know
contract recruitment consultant there's
especially if you're 360 right there's
so many different things that you could
spend time on
but do you have you actually taken a
step back and ask yourself
what do i need to make sure i do on a
daily basis that will
give me the outcome that i'm after and
like you said you you worked out how you
can win so i think that's such a great
insight
to people because when you really dig
deep it then like you just said
like you could have worried about all
these other things but you knew if you
got those two
candidates that fitted the criteria you
spent a lot of time working out that the
rest should take care of itself
and i guess not many recruiters or
average recruiters work out what is that
formula
what what are the things that's going to
help me win so i love that that's a
great inside ben
it's it's like think of it as dominos
right yeah
what's that first domino that you need
to flick over and if you
see any of these uh you know uh
fantastic feats
people build these stacks of dominoes it
starts at one and it knocks over and
then you get your biggest one at the end
right and so yeah it's it's not to say
that you
you should ignore all the other inputs
they're all important
right but there's there's always be
something
based on your experience or your or your
market that will be like
if i do that right if i if i get this
spot on then these other things will
knock forward and then and as you get
better at that maybe there's something
else that you move to but
too many people just um they float
around
i think and they float around and they
do a bit this and a bit of that
and they don't understand the ratios
they don't understand the
uh the real difference makers yeah
so the next thing i have we okay for ten
ten more minutes
yeah okay yeah okay cool so next thing
this is again really practical but a
really common question
is a lot of people want to know okay ben
so the the recruiters that you've seen
when they were performing i don't know
100k
150k years to then becoming
sort of double that 300k 400k plus
billers
what what changed in their day-to-day
from when they were 150k builders to
that
people want to know that like i don't
know if anything comes up for you then
it's this sort of
the the daily routines of the recruiter
that was so performing half
of what they were doing to now double
that what what changed
it's what i've talked about already
right it's the belief in
how you win so i i i can
i can think of top my head about 15
people
uh in the last two years
that have trebled quadrupled their
performance
one individual one individual in
particular
that i want i won't mention but this
person
the previous year right had a
performance that was
um disappointing right uh
barely did barely did the level of
performance that they wanted i think
for the full year did i think 300 000
u.s right and in the us that that that's
not a
that's not a particularly high benchmark
so so this person spent the christmas
break
trying to understand and trying to
uncover what what it is that would make
a difference in their market
and and the the key difference was
working with better commitment
right because what they were doing they
were working on so many different jobs
and requirements
everyone was window shopping and just
not going anywhere
and so came back and took this took this
attitude of right i'm going to
start working retained and before this
point
the person didn't really have a belief
in it because
they weren't confident in themselves
that they would fill it
because they'll they'll work at any type
of job so we we narrowed it down
in the january true story in the january
this individual started pitching
retainers won two retainers
i believe in in january and uh
by february had pulled 19 retains
signed retained businesses and um
by the march uh this person is now now
doing 200k
months right because they they have
they have set themselves up in this
position where
in the beginning they were pitching for
retain they weren't quite sure
by february like i can't work with you
until unless you retain because i've got
such a full
desk this demonstrated their credibility
immediately to that
their client uh portfolio and now
everybody wanted to work with this
person that person went from 300
that year the previous year to 1.1
million
u.s in the next year on perm right
night shifts a complete difference and
that difference was
because of understanding how that how
would they win in that market and the
way that
would win was great commitment uh and
which was working on retain so
went from no retainers to 1.1 million
and of that
about 800k of that was retained yeah so
that's
a very clear example it's it's um
there will be different nuances but
understand it and then commit to it
yeah i have to ask because it is a
really popular error and something that
comes up in the community a lot just
just
just really quickly i'm assuming you was
involved at this stage like
going from that shift from contingent to
pitch and retained or
they may have been doing some exclusive
sort of um agreements right but
now they're retained what were the what
would just the main sort of
before they gain confidence ryan it's a
lot easier to
pitch these things when you've already
done one or two and like you just said
they're they're going hey look
look i understand i can help you but i
can't
unless we agree this because this is
what's going on with us so
i guess just for people listening
because i feel like this is a real
really popular area for people
that want to develop one or two things
that that person really had to overcome
when they were sort of um making that
transition
of getting more commitment or retained
typically it's
i'd not believe not really believing in
in
the actual uh doing retain them or they
deliberate if
it's actually asking it always
it's always that it's people don't ask
like when you like have you asked
so i don't know anything that you can
share that they really had to overcome
that
maybe help them have that breakthrough
moment
i think you've hit the nail on the head
there hisham the first the first thing
is belief and when you and when you
uncover it largely it's because
when people have uh when people pitch
retained
it's their first instinct is they pitch
it for the most difficult job in their
market
right and they go look i'll only work if
it's retained
and and it's outside their scope they
don't understand it
the customers are terrible experience
you don't you don't place it they
they look they want their money back and
it just feels it's just awful
and in my opinion that's the wrong
approach right
actually retained should be in the sweet
spot of your market
right because the what the customer is
is um buying is your time and your
your resource right your service and so
what you're saying to them is i'll give
you
a great proportion of my time and retain
but you know if you don't want that
in retained then i'll i'll give you less
and so taking a customer on that journey
you know um i often talk about like
being able to demonstrate that
you know retained is is the greatest
level of service we offer
then you know there's other categories
but a b c yeah
and and um at these levels this is what
you're going to get from us
and you just be transparent and then
just ask them where do you want to sit
and i haven't met anybody that sits
there as a customer goes oh actually i
want to be a c
client can you just send me can you send
me you know candidates that every uh
you know once a week after everybody
else doesn't want them nobody
nobody talks like that you know
everybody wants a better level of
service so you've got to just be able to
be
able to articulate your value and stand
behind it the other problem i think
people haven't retained
is that they offer it as a discount
right and so
they have their contingent fee and they
go well if you do retain they'll give
you a discount
you need to flip that it needs to be the
other way around you are giving more of
your time
so if anything we're saying should be
more expensive it's the top
layer of service and so having the
belief in those two areas
makes makes a difference and then
something i talked about earlier
having expertise there's no point you
pitch and retain in areas you don't know
right because you're just going to
struggle to find them so if you if
you're a master of your particular
network you can get retained
you can fill it quickly you can make the
difference to the customer
and everybody can everybody wins um so
yeah that's
those are those those are three things
that i think make make the difference
other than
practicing right yeah have a just just
have a go
up you you spot on ask the question
you know i started retained and and if
they um
if the customer won't go and retain then
ask for an exclusive if they don't go
exclusive exactly yeah work for yeah
yeah work
work work your way work your way down
and and at some point then you decide
whether the customer is worth partnering
with
or not it's it's got to be your choice
right um
and i think that's i think that's really
powerful because
individuals have certain capacity you
know people
people have the ability to to work
certain amount in the time so categorize
and prioritize your time so you get your
best bang for your buck
awesome so before i um ask you the sort
of final five
questions always do some bit of a quick
fire round to finish
there's loads more that we could talk
about but i'm we'll sort of
wrap up here maybe we can get you back
on in in the future right
there's loads of sort of leadership
stuff i'd love to dig in with you but
i'm glad with where where it's gone so
i guess what i just wanted to hear from
you is your sort of
your your honest take on on the u.s
market
to sort of sort of pull this together
and obviously you can relate this to
sort of
i guess a real big opportunity for you
sgi and what you're building there so i
guess
if i'm honest with you before before
covid um i'd say a lot of or most
progressive recruitment companies had
america on their business plan
it seemed like that i spoke to because
of the things that we've spoken about
right so obviously this may have delayed
some people's plans or it just meant
like that yeah people have to wait
longer for visas which means more time
in the uk and building it etc
but what's your sort of honest take on
like how the u.s
recruitment market is going to be sort
of taking shape over the next sort of
two and a half
sort of five years if we can look that
far in the future i guess there will be
more and more companies probably uk
companies
entering the u.s market right and
wanting to to get some of this market
share
and i know there's plenty to go around
but what's your sort of take
on how are you feeling about the the u.s
market and how
yeah what do you think people should
think about and how they should view it
for people listen to us that may
be thinking about wanting to take their
recruitment career internationally and
particularly these days
this face is an incredible opportunity
like
no question i i i wanted to move there
in 2007
i ended up getting there in 2012 and i'm
i'm i'm still
i'm still here right so my actions speak
uh in terms of why
what i personally feel about this this
is a location
you know there's a bit of a fantasy in
terms of uh
it's it's it's a it's a mature market
there are some heavy heavyweight
uh us staffing businesses out there that
post incredible numbers
and so the the view tends to be that
um because there's not many british
companies that have gone and set up
there
which is which is true um the the people
in my network that i know are trading
in the us particularly last year and and
through to now focus on stem markets
they are producing
incredible returns incredible um double
digits you should make that really clear
for people because some people stem
markets what would you
just make that really clear for people
when you say stem markets what we're
talking
just to be clear for people um science
technology and engineering
and uh mathematics so okay cool
so though those those markets the
um have have have produced incredible
results
year on year and year on year and and
last year the companies that in the us
focused on that
um had had some some outrageous growth
so i i'm really really bullish about
the u.s opportunity we are seeing it
ourselves personally
my network are seeing are seeing
incredible uh
gains to be made following these
structures that we've talked about right
having expertise um deciding what what
you're going to be famous for
uh and and then having commitment into
that
market there are there's plenty
there's plenty to go around uh and and
it's a very exciting time
and what um always interested on this
like what
what sort of free states are you excited
by obviously you live in chicago and i'm
i guess in new york so i don't know what
what three states
because there's a lot of different sort
of states and places people can
look at right but i guess what what sort
of states excite you
maybe top three you're looking at um
so so currently uh california
the east coast and the midwest is is uh
is my lens of focus
um particularly around tech and and life
science
there there's tremendous hotbeds of of
talent
in terms of you know universities local
talent and also the types of
organizations there so
the us is vast it's it's inconceivable
in some in some cases to really get your
head around
so that's where my laser focus is right
now that that's where i'm feeling
greatest excitement yeah okay really
interesting
okay so i've got five questions for you
to finish this okay
so first question is if you could
change the industry what would you
improve
diversity i
there is there's such low barriers of
entry
into staffing
but it unfortunately it doesn't
transcend
uh across many diverse areas right so
i don't i don't just mean gender but i
also mean uh ethnic diversity
you know i just i just don't i think
there is a great
talent pool out there that doesn't get
tapped into because
people people farm in in in the same
areas right
they farm for talent from certain
universities or certain locations so
i'd love to see i'd love to see
um a more diverse
set of people in the industry yeah
amazing so the next question is
what book have you read that has had the
biggest impact on you so if you don't
read that could be an audio book or
maybe even a podcast but yeah what
what's the resource that you've read
that's really had an impact on you
there's a number of books that i i've
liked uh that i've picked up the one
that i've picked up most recently that i
read
i've read two or three times is the one
thing and
that what i love about that book is
the simplicity right this this idea
that you you know you should you should
try and zero
in on on one thing that's gonna that one
domino that's gonna make that difference
in whatever that you're focusing on
and so that's a it's a well-turned book
that is is
by my bedside that i i would i will just
dip into every now and again
um just to remind myself about some of
the things i need to be
working on so yeah i found that a
particularly powerful book
to help center me yeah amazing
so next question is if you could write a
linkedin post that could be seen by
every single recruitment consultant
across the world what would you want it
to say
um i'm hiring for 25 people
[Laughter]
um what i wanted to say i don't know i'm
i i post now so i there are
so many different topics that's that's a
hard thing to it's a hard thing to
to answer um what would you want to
communicate to a room full of
like-minded recruitment consultants it's
maybe a better way to look at
yeah okay well i guess if i'm talking to
people or giving any advice
um the things i'd want to impart
is to encourage people to understand
their purpose and
understand that it's it's the juice is
worth the squeeze
if you understand what you want to
squeeze right
yeah and and double down on that by
having
a simple approach you know focus on that
one domino
that will lead on to the next then you
go to the next to the next and so
yeah perhaps perhaps that amazing
so next one is uh what did you spend
your first biggest commission paycheck
on
oh wow i remember
getting my first uh five figure uh
paycheck um i
my wife my girlfriend at the time but um
we we went down to london
we stayed at the sanderson hotel got a
uh got a suite
um went and had uh dinner at
uh carriages did a lot of shopping
um when went to went to a show on the
west end
um and well we stayed there we stayed
there in london for the weekend
and uh and spent about 80
of it
[Laughter]
we just wanted to
just wanted to have fun right and yeah
and
and just be not think about what we're
spending so just yeah just have fun with
what we're doing
yeah just that freedom of like yeah do
you want to do that yeah let's just go
and do it
and and so i talked about purpose you
know that that feeling gave me so
it sparked so much joy that let me want
to go and do it again
you didn't walk back do you didn't go
back home with a rolex or anything like
that
um i i didn't i didn't get that then no
but um okay i did we did get jewelry
um and uh and and things like that yeah
yeah i
didn't no i didn't get roller to that
side nice okay
so final question what what's ultimate
goal
for your recruitment career ben
for me um i wanna i felt like i
um i've had a great 19 years at s3
i've got a lot of energy to go again and
my my goal i want to
i want to build something that is
long-lasting i want to build something
that
creates an opportunity not just for me
but for the hundreds of people that i
i'm yet to know are yet to hire and i
want to make an impact right i want to
discover
more of my potential i i feel like i've
had a fantastic
inning so far but it's untapped it's
it's it's
it's not even it's not even halfway um
where i think i could go and so i want
to discover my potential
and and being able to build something
again really gives me that excitement
and and and going along that journey
with others and watching them
take their opportunity discovering their
own potential makes
gives this fills up me up with joy
ben it's been an absolute pleasure
thanks for coming
thank you very much really